Paramount is no longer the home of Star
Trek welcome to Sid Trek your SciFi TV
and Movie
[Music]
Channel so last year the good Star Trek
movies not the JJ ABS movies the good
Star Trek movies moved from Max HBO Max
back then to now Max or whatever it's
called this week might be called
something completely different by the
time I release this video but they
removed from Max over to Paramount plus
and Paramount plus became the home of
Star
Trek as at the start of this year though
in the United States those movies the
good Star Trek movies not the JJ Abrams
ones the good ones moved back from
Paramount plus to Max and they're now
longer on Paramount plus so Star Trek is
no longer the home of Star Trek
especially considering Prodigy is now on
Netflix now we've been talking a lot on
this channel about paramounts problems
and how it hopes to use Star Trek to
actually generate income and how it will
only be able to make certain Star Trek
projects if it actually like Farms them
out to other Studios something it was
doing a few years ago obviously perard
season one or two were only on um Prime
uh lower decks the same but then they
all moved over to pount plus during this
whole process of the of par basically
desperately trying to make the stream
and service work they spent way too much
money
it didn't work and now they're going
back to that original business model but
more than that we hear these rumors
about Warner Brothers and Paramount
potentially merging now that merger I'm
being told will be of what we know used
to know as Paramount so the Paramount
movie and TV company not
CBS CBS and Paramount will split once
again like they did a few years ago and
Paramount will hopefully emerge with
Warner Brothers and the current owners
will continue to own CBS which will be
kept separate Star Trek is moving
apparently towards becoming its own
entity and they're going to create Star
Trek Studios by potentially buying out
Alex curtzman from secret hideout and
creating Star Trek Studios which would
then control the IP now it's unclear who
would actually own that company but they
would be producing Star Trek the plan
long term
is for Star Trek to become almost its
own entity that it would exist on
several different streaming platforms as
it has done the last few years that
movies could be produced by different
production companies as it has done the
last few years and that basically they
would try to make this big almost
multi-platform
franchise that wouldn't just belong to
Paramount but Paramount would take
advantage of it I.E they would get in
the money but other people people would
be taken the risk this is just one more
example of us moving towards that as
Paramount are using its own franchise
its own money but taking the money from
HBO they're allowing HBO to give them
money now this again is just moving
towards this final goal and it's an
interesting one but what do you guys
think Star Trek in America is no longer
solely on Paramount Plus the original
movies not the J.J abrs films the good
ones I'm being sarcastic I like the JJ
abrs movies they are actually good films
they're just not Star Trek so the
original Star Trek movies they're all
now on Max what do you guys think about
that and what does it say about the
long-term plan for Star Trek get into
the comments and tell me exactly what
you
think it's really interesting now that
everyone in Hollywood has got back to
work and there are some interesting
rumors and news coming out already I've
got a couple more videos coming up but
one particularly about Stargate that I
think you're going to be very interested
by so keep an eye open for it in the
meantime I will get news out to you as
quickly as I possibly can so don't
forget to subscribe and like the video
and come back and meet us where we're
going to be talking more about sci-fi as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
[Music]
time